[Music]
America's under threat and it looks a
lot like this they will not come into
our homes and take away our right a
small group of armed right-wing
activists have occupied a federal
wildlife facility in Oregon in what they
call a stand against the tyranny of the
federal government and this oppressive
tyrannical government sounds extreme but
their actions aren't new or isolated
rather they're part of a long American
tradition these men are part of the
patriot movement which consists of
hundreds of right-wing groups and
heavily armed militias united by an
anti-government ideology so where did it
come from the patriot movement exploded
when obama was elected in 2008 and while
several of today's right-wing groups
aren't explicitly racist some of their
ideas are rooted in the white
supremacist reaction to the civil rights
movement in the 70s and 80s a group
called Posse Comitatus believed a secret
group of jews controlled the country and
that black Americans weren't really
citizens because the 14th amendment
wasn't legitimate but some of their
other ideas have become common talking
points in the patriot movement today we
do know that a lot of these talking
points and tactics like his ideas of
nullification that the county or state
governments don't have to follow federal
laws that the County Sheriff is the
highest authority to County that people
right-wingers radical right wingers
should for militias that they can
interpret the Constitution with more
authority than the Supreme Court can ARF
all ideas that came out of a 1970s white
supremacist group called Posse Kermit
Aras so when did these right-wing groups
gain steam right after the 1993 Waco
Siege when federal agents attempted to
seize illegal guns from a religious
groups compound to Patriots the violent
response of the federal officials
confirmed their fears of living under a
government that was coming for their
guns and was willing to kill its own
citizens over the years membership of
Patriot groups died down but the number
of these groups surged after the
election of America's first black
president at the beginning of Obama's
first term there were about 100
see Patriot groups in 2012 that number
ballooned to more than 1300 one of the
most notable and influential the tea
party what the patriot movement has been
successful at doing is sort of blending
and honing or masking over some of these
racist ideas and sort of putting them
through a funnel of anti-government
rhetoric fast forward to 2014 when
Nevada rancher cliven Bundy refused to
pay fees for grazing his cattle on
federal land hundreds of armed
militiamen from the patriot movement
showed up to defend him against federal
law enforcement federal officials had
confiscated Bundy's herd but fearing
another Waco they eventually back down
at gunpoint Bundy one and it energized
the patriot movement and now the
occupation of the Wildlife Refuge in
Oregon led by his sons has become the
latest rallying point for Patriots while
a lot of the anger of these patriot
movement groups is fueled by conspiracy
theories that range from the government
wanting to seize Americans guns to the
implementation of Sharia law there are
also legitimate grievances about federal
handling and distribution of resources
and that speaks to a lot of Americans so
who does the patriot movement speak for
and can it become the new mainstream
[Music]